Southwest Medical the sponsors of this
segment are here for our seniors Rocky
spoke to a doctor about how they're
keeping older adults in the community
healthy and focused on Wellness what are
some special areas that older adults
need to pay attention to it's a good
question I think this might lead to one
of the most successful outcomes in their
health care and I think four areas that
can cause
problems or help us rather stay healthy
is our Elder focusing
flexible their balance is good so that
they avoid Falls their strength and
endurance those are very very important
for staying healthy
they can maintain or restore these areas
with physical activity a variety of
activities of best and reduce the risk
of injury exercise also AIDS against
depression weight gain and uh
both of those in combinations Morrison
conditions like incontinence for example
also in addition to all of that I think
Health screenings are probably one of
the most important things to remember we
always check weight on patients and that
helps us determine the BMI we always
check their blood pressures when they
come in and that helps us you know
diagnose early hypertension prevent
Strokes heart attacks diabetes also we
check routine labs for this cholesterol
fat cholesterol is no good cholesterol
so great we love our food right
colorectal cancer I know we bug all of
our patients about getting a colonoscopy
nobody wants to get an unpleasant
procedure but it's important for women
specifically we do mammograms and Pap
smears and farm Medicare Advantage
patients you know they get an annual
wellness and checkups and they can also
get bone densities they can get EKG
tests they can get testing for their
circulation nerves and diabetic and
mental health as well I'll often Care
community centers provide opportunities
for older adults that attend social
activities make new friends and learn
about health topics important to this
stage in their life Social Club is open
to the community you don't need to be a
patient of Southwest Medical Center of
these activities some of the other
things that they can take advantage of
are they can go for a swim they can golf
low impact exercise classes yoga can be
very very helpful and balanced in
helping you balance and strengthening
your gait Jacob dancing some of my I
actually have a I call her young 92 year
old but she goes dancing every single
weekend and she goes that's what's
keeping me healthy so we encourage our
viewers to mark their calendars and
visit us at the fall into good health
and wellness fair this is going to be
happening on a Wednesday November 9th
from 9 A.M to 2 p.m and it'll be at
Sam's Town Hotel
um you and your friend can enjoy our
medicine on the Move mobile Wellness
Center on location for the optimum Care
Network Nevada members to receive their
mammograms Health screenings at no cost
thank you Southwest Medical for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-877-5199 or visit
smalv.com Las Vegas now we'll be right
back
[Music]